اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده لن تستورد النفط الروسي
بموجب خطه الحد الاقصى للاسعار التي اعلنت
عنها مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
وقالت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه ان استيراد
النفط الروسي محظورا الى الولايات المتحده
بموجب امر تنفيذي سيظل ساريا حتى بعد بعد
وضع حد اقصى لسعر النفط الروسي ومن المقرر
ان تعلن مجموعه السبع والاتحاد الاوروبي
عن سقف في اسعار صادرات النفط الروسيه
المنقوله بحرا والذي سيبدا تصديقه في
الخامس من ديسمبر المقبل
من جيت على البيت الابيض انا واشنطن صوت
واصل ودعم فرضي حد اقصى لسعر الضغط الروسي
للحد من قدره الرئيس بوتن على تمويل
الحربي في اوكرانيا ونقل صحيفه مول ستريج
جورنال عن مصادر مطلعه ان الولايات
المتحده وحلفاءها يناقشون تحديد سعر النفط
الروسي عند 60 دولارا للبرميل وبحسب
الصحيفه الامريكيه فانه بموجب العقوبه
ستمتنعوا الدول مجموعه السبع والاتحاد
الاوروبي واستراليا عن تقديم الخدمات
البحريه لشحنات نفطر روسي ما لم يتم بيعها
باقل من الحد الاقصى المحدد